bonsoir après son beau merci d'être avec
nous l'hybris kolélas parfait kolélas
saint l'opposant qui avait été testée
positive vendredi
tout est allé très vite on a vu ces
images on imagine que que le pays est
sous le choc
tout à fait je peux chercher sur des
villages kremlin qui apparaissent
l'allemand thomas le testament politique
que vit brice parfait kolélas clair à
félicitant les tôles congolais et puis
laisse à sa famille ici c'est à dire
qu'il faut se battre les meilleurs
accomplir de droit il faut se lever se
battre pour à conquérir ce droit et en
opérant de ti les appeler ses partisans
à les fautifs que les changements la
mort l'homme pour tv le message bref là
il tentait de lui pour sa famille sont
partis politiques pour le peuple
congolais
on imagine que que ce message va
probablement être entendu parce que tout
de même il avait réussi plus ou moins
fédérer derrière lui une partie de
l'opposition
son décès c'est un coup dur pour la
tendance politique
oui c'est un coup moi très dur pour
l'opposition coup très dur pour
l'alternance évidemment les personnes
n'étaient dus qu'à lille juillet les
autres membres de l'opposition que cette
élection allait changer la donne
politique
le brassage il on a vu que certains
candidats n'ont pas même s'ils n'ont
même pas pu battre campagne comics doit
faute de moyens que c'était illégal par
rapport à venir
une vérité et que donc il fallait
effectivement cher jouer le jeu
démocratique a jusqu'au bout sur ce que
c'est ce qu'ils embauchent et on en test
elle en particulier vivent brice parfait
kolélas si on comprend bien finalement
denis sassou nguesso est en bonne place
pour partir pour un
un énième mandat ben tout a été fait
tout est fait pour justement que il
conquiert un tâche et amanda rodrigues
restons attachés à aucun résultat
d'ailleurs le peuple congolais à
manifester une forme de lassitude charge
justement à ces systèmes qui seront
utiles se renouvelle pas et on agit lui
pas des par exemple refusé de participer
à ces élections qu'il fallait c'est
l'ancien parti le parti de l'ancien
président pascal lissouba a refusé
d'aller aux élections parce qu'elle
considérait que c'était joué dans une
avance que les dés étaient pipés
qu'à cela ne tienne effectivement on va
encore avoir admis fassions des sceaux
pour un mandat de cinq ans encore et ça
pose une énorme question au peuple
congolais mais surtout à l'opposition
congolaise de savoir comment elle va
s'en sortir à cette énième défaite en
choisit les à l'élection présidentielle
et qu'il faudrait c'est la structure de
toute manière alors on précise que les
observateurs des nations unies et de
l'union européenne n'ont pas été invités
à surveiller
l'élection que disent les les pays
occidentaux sur cette probable
réélection sans surprise et l'absence a
priori de renouvellement démocratique au
congo pour le moment le silence
assourdissant en particulier de la
france à l'état n'aime pas le fait que à
personne au niveau de l'union européenne
de ce fait d'illusions sur le résultat
ya une personne qui posait une question
a fait malicieuse du genre en lançant
l'une européenne on entend la france
quand c'est par exemple venezuela tantôt
sur des lits à crier haut et fort à la
fraude mais quand il s'agit du congo
ouvrage agile on les entend moins
et là les observateurs qui ont été au
congo de l'afrique
évidemment le poste à contredire ce que
le gouvernement du congo
si on me les propos de denis sassou
n'guesso qui se satisfait qui se
contentent justement de la manière dont
les choses elle les élections l'élection
présidentielle a été organisée mais on
l'a vu effectivement dans le requiert
beaucoup de lacunes dans l'organisation
merci alfred shango maître de
conférences à la sorbonne nouvelle
d'avoir été avec nous